geomagnetic pull shifts it's not that
the Earth flips upside down um it's just
that the interior of the core
transitions it can cause effects on
Earth but I am not convinced that there
isn't a tumble um and so listen to this
scripture Joshua 10:13 it says so the
sun Stood Still and the moon stopped
till the nation Avenged itself on its
enemies as it's written in the book of
josar the sun stopped in the middle of
the sky and delayed going down about a
full day uh what and let me do one more
and this is from the Quran book 4 8 he
who seeks repentance from the Lord uh or
Allah before the rising of the Sun from
the West before the day of the
Resurrection D Allah turns him to his
mercy so it talks about the day when the
Sun rises in the west now just to
clarify the actual um it's believed that
that just has to do with when you pass
away you go into the West so it's not
talking about the Earth it is what I'm
trying to say is that I am I know that
the other side will say that's not a
correct translation for it